[Music]
moving on to other news now that's 100
days since fighting started in Sudan
between the Army and the paramilitary
rapid support forces the conflict has
increased food shortages and worsened
hunger before the violence began 16
million people didn't have enough to eat
but now the United Nations says another
3 million have no access to food
um Sharif reports
Muhammad Ali runs one of the few grocery
stores that remain open in southern
umduman part of the Sudanese Capital
kartum but he's running low on stock
since early May
the area has seen some of the fiercest
fighting in recent weeks cutting off
supply lines
basic necessities are scarce flour milk
beans oil and drinks stalks are
dwindling and the prices are constantly
Rising with no sign of stopping items
are already expensive and the cost of
transporting them is also High
most businesses have either run out of
goods or have shut down as the security
situation did
the violence has left millions of people
trapped in their homes
our situation is dire especially
economically many people haven't been
paid or received a pension for more than
three months people are struggling to
get by and who knows what will happen
tomorrow
for the nearly 3 million Sudanese
displaced within the country mostly from
Khartoum a meal is a luxury they can't
afford about one-third of the population
didn't have enough to eat before the
conflict began now the world food
program says more than 19 million people
are facing food shortages
Aid agencies say fighting looting and a
lack of access to affected areas are
hampering efforts to deliver Aid this is
one of the most complicated humanitarian
responses anywhere in the world at the
moment insecurity is making it very
dangerous for humanitarian workers to
push further into the country so the
first thing that we need ideally is the
conflict to end
if that doesn't happen then we need to
at least ensure that there is
humanitarian access and safe passage so
that we can move into places like Darfur
into the quarterfans so that we can
reach the populations in desperate need
at this time first the warn Ukraine
costs full prices to soar making basic
Goods unaffordable for millions of
people worldwide now an internal
conflict has aggravated conditions for
Sudanese pushing Millions to the brink
of starvation
and a correspondent Mohammed Val is
joining us live from Port Sudan Mohammed
those signs of the conflict debating
despite numerous rounds of talks
that's right Emily and that's the main
problem here for the civilians that
there is no light at the end of the
tunnel for most of them they have seen
negotiations here and there in foreign
capitals Regional Powers trying to
intervene and so on but they haven't
seen a genuine will on the part of the
of the warring parties to end this
conflict anytime soon there is this
zero-sum game being adopted by the two
sides each one of them thinking that
they can definitively crush the other
side and finish them and for the
civilians they're not concerned by this
it's not their business they want their
life to get better they want relief and
one of the main issues in Sudan here for
civilians is children the situation of
children in Sudan is of utmost concern
to many organizations here and I'm here
with our guest today is Ted Cheban his
Deputy executive director of Unicef uh
much for being with Al Jazeera we would
like to ask you about this press release
that came overnight by UNICEF a lot of
very concerning information there tell
us about it
we're here on the 100th day of a
conflict that has visited unprecedented
harm and pain to Sudanese children and
their families 24 million Sudanese are
in need of humanitarian assistants
that's 13 million children one in every
two children in Sudan since the conflict
started
reported cases that are verified have
indicated that we've had 437 children
that have been killed over 2 000
children that have been injured that's a
child every hour that has either been
killed or injured and that's what's been
reported the actual cases are much much
higher and we know that this was already
a fragile situation we have 700 000
children in Sudan that are severely
acutely malnourished if you do not get
assistance to a child who is severely
acutely malnourished that child is at
high risk of mortality UNICEF and
partners are on the ground we're making
a difference we've been able to reach 3
million children with health supplies
including support to responding to acute
malnutrition but much more needs to be
done tell us about the the challenges
you have in trying to reach those
children and bringing Aid to them so
firstly is the issue of access there
needs to be access to places like Darfur
to be able to get into cartoon safely
and part of the work that we have done
over the last two days is to build on
what the country Again country team has
done in country and enter into further
discussions with the authorities on the
ground so that bureaucratic impediment
to access visas travel permits stay
permits are simplified for us to be able
to get into the areas where the children
are most at need we of course are
providing the support already but we
need simplified procedures to be able to
do this even more easily and more
regularly secondly is uh financing the
UNICEF appeal currently is only nine
percent funded we're asking for 840
million dollars and we're were only nine
percent funded without resources we
cannot do our job with regards to your
dealings with the warring parties in
this conflicts you're trying to reach
people you know that a large number of
the population are within the areas
under the control of Rapid support
forces and the others are within the
areas of the control of the government
are you talking to both sides are they
giving you access to the areas where you
can reach children bring Aid to them
on behalf of children on behalf of
humanitarian assistance we will speak to
all parties concerned as we speak now
today as we sit here there is a convoy
planned from uh Chad into Janina the
capital of westar4 it's a cross-border
convoy and in order to be able to secure
that Convoy we have made and had
negotiations with the Sudanese Armed
Forces with the rapid support forces as
well as with the local Wally we are
speaking to all in order to get
sustained access to children thank you
very much
Deputy executive director of Unicef and
by that you can have a clear picture
about the tragedy in Sudan particularly
with regards to children and the
inability for ngos to reach them with
Aid something of deep concern here to
millions of Sudanese families in
particular
Muhammad thank you very much for that
that is Muhammad Val joining us live
from Port Sudan thank you